all right joining me now is a reporter
who broke this story Luke rosiak
investigative reporter for the daily
wire he's also the author of Race To The
Bottom uncovering the secret forces
destroying American public education
Luke now you've noted that the grand
jury report found that the
superintendent's concealment was so
extensive that the school board didn't
even know about it
until you broke the story what that was
pretty wild I broke this story a little
over a year ago and now this jury of
nine citizens county has found facts
that I couldn't get because they use
subpoenas they used compelled testimony
now the school board members would not
testify until they were within two hours
of being arrested but they got documents
they did get that testimony and what we
find is that there was a series of
failures continuing failures including
just days before the rape a teacher's
aide emailed her boss that she did not
want to be held responsible if anyone
gets hurt because of this kid now her
boss said I question your motives
implying that the lady the teacher that
complained was transphobic and so they
did nothing to the kids so they're
afraid so they want they want the
teachers to be afraid they want
administrators who don't agree with this
agenda afraid and they want the parents
afraid they want everybody afraid that's
right and so they left this kid in
school they did nothing to him and just
days later he raped after that he's
charged he's wearing an ankle bracelet
they just transfer for him to a
different school and again the grand
jury found a series of additional
instances of this guy
is there a massive lawsuit involving the
parents of this girl and right now I
think we're going to see that with Scott
Smith you know that could be a lot of
money on the table oh my god well Luke I
want to read you a portion of this grand
jury report when you reached out to
Loudoun County schools for a statement
to confirm or dispute any of the facts
weighed by our Loudoun County school
public admin information officer sent it
to his colleagues and said I believe
this should receive immediate attention
now this was months after the assault
he's seemed concerned that the story was
about to get national attention that is
all that mattered to them not this young
woman not the fact that other young
women and other students were vulnerable
at these other schools it was the pr
that they didn't want the bad PR that's
one of the things that's shocking there
was an email that went out after the
first rape that said the only thing that
happened at school today was an unruly
parent and that's why you saw police on
campus now if you need counseling from
having to see the police we'll offer you
counseling but there was no threat to
the safety of students and we find out
as you mentioned the rapist was on the
loose that entire time while they were
seeking restraining water against the
father now that email was at the father
of the victim that email was attributed
as I reported at the time to the
principal but we found out from this
grand jury the school district's
Prescott the spokesman wrote it and the
superintendent edited it so this is all
about PR and as I was saying they moved
the kid to the new school and hear
harasses other girls and they make him
write on a piece of paper I will not
touch others I will not ask for intimate
photos this is after the kid is wearing
an ankle bracelet because he's facing
felony sodomy charges again they have
warning signs again they do nothing and
a few days after that he takes a girl
into a an empty classroom strangles her
and sexually assaults her
the woke agenda and fanaticism trumps
everybody else's rights even your right
to be left alone and not victimized or
in this case sodomized and raped
unbelievable Luke I don't know what
we've done without your reporting on
this initially you really were the
Catalyst for all this thank you so much
thank you we appreciate it and obviously
all the parents hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else